الاف السودانيين يتدفقون يوميا عبر
المعابر البريه مع مصر هربا من القتال في
بلدانهم تدفق يثير مخاوف السلطات المصريه
بسبب التاثيرات السلبيه المتوقعه على
اقتصاد البلاد الذي يعاني بالفعل من تبعات
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بالاضافه
لاستضافه لملايين اللاجئين من دول عربيه
خلال الاعوام الماضيه في دعم دولي لهذا
الموضوع عشان خاطر نقدر ان احنا نتحمل ولا
سيما ان احنا عندنا فوق الخمسه مليون
سوداني موجودين بالفعل واجمالي زي ما صرح
سياده الرئيس اجمالي اللي موجودين من
اللاجئين يفوق 9 مليون الوضع على الحدود
اثر بالفعل على حركه تنقل البضائع بين
البلدين عشرات الناقلات تعجز عن المرور في
الاتجاهين
25 يوم
وطبعا الخسائر دي ان العربيه واقفه وانا
واقف وصاحب البضاعه مش عاوز يقول ارجع على
اساس ان الحال يتصالح ونخش فانا طبعا ما
هوش هنخش مستحيل ان احنا نخش بعد الضرب ده
وبعيدا عن الاقتصاد فان كثيرين يحذرون من
تداعيات استمرار المواجهات في السودان
وزياده اعداد النازحين على الامن القومي
المصري فهناك خشيه من محاولات استغلال
الفوضى لتسلل عناصر من الجماعات المتطرفه
لدخول الاراضي المصريه في حدود مفتوحه مع
ليبيا وبالتالي ممكن ان يكون هذا ممر
للعناصر الارهابيه وعناصر القريبه المنظمه
دائما ما ترتبط الارهاب بعناصر الجريمه
المنظمه العناصر بيبقى بيوفروا الدعم
اللازم سواء المادي او المعنوي او
اللوجستي للعناصر الارهابيه وبالتالي هذه
العناصر دي بتلاقي في الحاله بتلاقي فيه
ملاذ امن القاهره مستمره في العمل مع
شركائها الاقليميين والدوليين في محاوله
لوقف القتال وتثبيت الهدن وعوده الاستقرار
للسودان وتبقى الامال معقوده على نجاح
مبادرات الدوليه والاقليميه في اقناع طرفي
النزاع في وقف الاقتتال حتى لا تتفاقم
الاثار السلبيه على جميع دول الجوار احمد
عثمان العربيه من معبر ارجيل على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات